hello everyone and welcome to Game three
of the 1972 match of the century between
Boris vasilevich Spassky and the Robert
James Fisher now I know what you're
thinking dude you can just show us game
three without showing us game two
well the reason I'm not going to be
showing game two is because Game two of
this match never actually happened now
you've seen Game one after Game one on
the evening of the second game when it
should have happened Fischer basically
gave an ultimatum to the chief arbiter
of the match German Grandmaster a lot of
Schmidt he said either the cameras go or
I go saying that he will only play if
they turn down all the cameras which is
which was basically unthinkable mr.
Chester Fox and his company they bought
all the television rights for this match
and they invested a lot in organizing
this some $60,000 they thought they will
be able to get a get it-get returns you
know after the match is over via
television rights and this seemed a very
I mean a Fischer basically argued for
for a couple of months during the
negotiations for the match that both he
him and Spassky I should get some 30%
not only from the gate money but also
from television rights so it seemed the
why would you do this why would you not
only deprive yourself of this money this
30% of television rights but also
there's like this huge price fund if you
go I mean if you don't play the match
you're not gonna get any money you're
gonna ruin your reputation and you're
basically not gonna get anything so it
was very interesting but still Fischer
did not back down from from his request
and it was some the the game to already
started as a Fischer had the white
pieces he had to make the first move
Spassky started the clock and 35 minutes
have already elapsed on Fischer's clock
now the rules go if one hour passes by
and the Fischer doesn't show up he
immediately forfeits the game so mr.
Chester Fox who had the rights all the
television rights for this match
actually backed it down at this moment
he said okay I'll remove all the cameras
just you know invite Fisher I want him
to play and then perhaps for game three
we're gonna think of an arrangement how
how we can also both use the cameras and
the that the match continues and the
Fisher said okay I agree but I also want
my thirty five minutes back
but this unfortunately was not possible
there was no rule that stipulated that
turning the clock time on the clock back
was possible so the chief arbitral otter
Schmidt couldn't do anything about this
Fisher didn't show up the one hour
elapsed and the Fisher lost Game two so
now it was pretty much over it's
spassky's already to two to zero in the
lead and Fisher blew his chances he
should have had had the white pieces in
this game so probably no one in the
world not even Spassky nor the Russian
Federation or the chief arbiter anyone
didn't think that the match would
actually continue and that Fisher would
agree to play under these terms so
Spassky I think he went on a fishing
expedition he also went on a fishing
expedition to catch salmon during the
whole negotiations when Fisher was in
New York and not coming to Reykjavik and
it's not like a joke or anything or a
wordplay he actually did go on a fishing
expedition so no one thought that Fisher
would come back there was even news from
some of the reporters that that Robert
Fisher booked a flight from Reykjavik to
Iceland but it was actually some German
tourists also named Robert Fischer and
you know it was really tense and it
really did seem like the match of the
century would go to waste but then
before the third game started Fisher's
lawyer Paul Marshall and his second
William Lombardi they made a phone call
to the chief arbiter a lot of Schmidt
and they asked him if it was possible
for Game three to be played in the back
room that was behind the main stage so
although unlikely water Schmidt called
Spassky and he asked him does he agree
to these terms and this was actually the
this moment of all he responds key
immediately agreed he said yes I will
play him in the in the backstage and
this was a moment where Sparky
Spassky could have single-handedly have
won the match if it was a if it was you
know if you ask the Russian Federation
or pretty much anyone especially should
have said no and you know the match
would have gone to him now it I don't
know if it would be like the
championship will be over or would there
be a second match in Moscow between
Spassky and Petrosyan probably there
would be one but to the Russian Chess
Federation it wouldn't really matter
because the the title of the world chess
champion would stay in Russia or the
Soviet Union but to everyone's surprise
Spassky agreed to these terms so it's
game 3a but soon as possible very soon
regret regret this and a lot of people
said that this was a huge mistake and
Spassky sparked you know playing into
Fischer's a psychological warfare
although i i i personally don't think it
was a means of psychological warfare on
Fischer's part that fish were just
really the cameras really did affect him
in a negative way but you know it's it's
hard to prove anything now but ok the
game 3 is supposed to start
Spassky makes his first move on the
third game Spassky plays d4 and the
Spassky surprise Fischer is nowhere to
be found so it's Game three they agreed
on all of Fischer's terms they move the
cameras Fischer did come here and it
took some I believe some 15 minutes for
Fischer to arrive Fischer did arrive but
he didn't make his move just immediately
rather he kept complaining to the chief
arbitral water Schmidt and he was
complaining about cameras making a sound
so now they had to turn all of the
cameras even those Fischer couldn't see
but he could actually hear them so they
had one closed-circuit camera that one
made no sound and that was the only
camera that was allowed the you know to
record them so it wasn't really a great
spectacle for the audience they had just
the you know that soundless scene and
[Music]
basically a soundless replica of the
board so after all that settled down
official finally makes his first move
some five minutes after he he's not
complaining and he responds nice to f6
okay we have c4 e6 Knight to f3
everything is the same as in Game one
but here unlike game one fish doesn't go
for the Queen's Gambit the client would
be five rather he goes with c5 so
inviting Spassky rather challenging
Spassky to Albinoni
and here after all of this we can call
it psychological warfare as possibly
actually accepts the challenge he plays
d5 and goes straight into Fischer's
famous Benoni
which if you remember the palma de mer
kind interest on all tournament Fischer
played a brilliant game in the Benoni
with the black pieces against the
against the Wolfgang woman but ok eek
after sandy 5c captures d6 we have
Knight to c3 g6 and here this is a
pretty standard position of the benoni
where moves like efore have been played
h3 but you can develop the darks for a
bishop but here Spassky actually goes
Knight to detail what did this move he
goes into a different variation and ok
this is nothing out of the ordinary
Knight B to d7 by Fischer and now you
could go something like nice to see 4 to
stop a blacks development of the bishop
as you're attacking this but then Knight
to b6 is perfectly fine the Queen out
defends the pawn also you're offering a
trade of knights and you get a semi-open
file for your rook so here as Paschal
goes e4 and okay Bishop to g7 Bishop to
e2 we have castles castles rook to e8
and this is a the a well-known line
everyone if you've played the Benoni you
you've encountered this line where glue
you're in his book says that a very
often response here would be a 4 but
here as possibly actually has a home
preparation ready he plays Queen to c2
and what this movie legally changed his
book he says that okay it does save
white a temple when you look at the
other variations but on the other hand
the Queen now
is the kingside and it's when the queen
is on b1 the queen better battery really
keeps an eye on this g4 square but now
that the queen is on c2 the Queen might
not be so useful on the Kings side and
this really how Fischer takes advantage
of this slight imperfection in the
positioner although I mean if you ask an
engine it's not even an imperfection but
if you remember if remember I made a
video on Todd's game against the gherkin
it's a tall had the black pieces and he
also played the Benoni and at one point
Queen to c2 was played by Gorgon it's a
and tal saw that by playing Queen to c2
white left his rook that was on e one
okay undefended and then really
unleashed a powerful attacked here a
fishery uses a similar idea and he plays
Knight to h5 a very nice idea because
now as there's no Queen on the one you
can't just capture an age 5 and then
gobble up the pawn as well so here
Fischer is offering a knight and also
he's offering to double to mess up his
pawn structure but what else is there I
mean aside from capturing the night if
you don't capture the knight what do you
play if you go something like Knight to
f3 because you do have to develop your
pieces make room for the bishop and
everything then Fisher simply continues
Knight to e5 and all is well here now
the light square bishop can also come
into play f5 will be an idea black is
black is excellent here so I mean it's
offered you have to take it Spassky
captures a bunch of characters on h5 we
have G captures on h5 and then now
Knights the c4 pressuring the d6 pawn
and ok Knight to e5 by Fischer
this is Fischer simply keeps developing
we have Knight back to III as Spassky
doesn't want to keep an eye on this f5
square and the now comes Queen to h4 a
very nice idea by Fischer already this
is move 14 and already there are very
unpleasant threats on the King side and
here as paska assesses the position
correctly he simply continues developing
Bishop to d2 but to play a move like
Bishop to d2 you have to like thoroughly
thoroughly analyze that nice to f3 isn't
a death threat
because here Knight to f3 it seems a
very powerful for example pawn captures
and now
five already you're threatening
checkmate and okay rook f31 you can make
some room for the king but let's say
bush up to h3 bishop sorry Queen to h3
is coming now threatening Bishop
captures on H 2 then F 4 you block
simply brush up characters and now 92 F
1 the night now guards the h2 pawn and
also you open up a discovered attack
against blacks Bishop Queen g4 check now
comes Knight to g3 and now you have to
see that after Bishop captures Queen
captures and h4 if black wins a piece
back and also started a very nice attack
then black will definitely be better but
here Queen to h6 is simply too powerful
a move H captures on g3 and now comes
Luke to e3 and now you see that there is
no defense against rook to g3 either
winning the queen or checkmating the
black King for example even if you
capture this G captures on h2 simply
King captures again you will either face
a rope to g3 and you lose the Queen
Queen s treason possible rope is
covering that as well if you move the
king or queen then a rope to g3 will
simply lead to checkmate so Bishop to d2
a very nice move by Spassky and very
precise calculation that Knight to f3 it
doesn't work just yet Knight to g4
Fischer simply wants to imply a
positional idea wants to improve his
pawn structure he is threatening
checkmate on h2 of course you do have to
prevent this Knight captures on g4 was
played a chapters on g4 now the pawn
structure on the King set is now again
very nice and here Bishop to f4 as poss
he had to play this you do have to bring
the bishop over here and keep an eye on
this very strong diagonal also you have
to keep an eye on the e5 square and here
if Fischer insists on this Bishop to e5
move you can simply capture it rook
captures your threatening rook to h5 but
it doesn't matter even f4 rook to h5 you
can simply go g3 the Queen now is
definitely useful on c2 as she guards
the h2 she guards the h2 pawn so doesn't
really work so here Fischer finds a
different idea Queen to f6 rhe
maneuvering the Queen by attacking the
bishop and now if you move the bishop
you get h 5 and then h 4 is coming so
instead after Queen to f6
Spassky places g3 okay Bishop to d7 you
figure has to also keep developing his
pieces we have a four and now comes B
six now Fischer will try to prove that
his majority on the Queen side is much
more important than spassky's majority
on the King side which is often the case
if you have more points than your
opponent on the side of the board where
there are no kings then that is
definitely considered an advantage rook
F 2 e 1 we have a 6 and here Fischer is
preparing B 5 now he's starting to push
on the Queen side
rook to e2 Spassky doesn't really find
any any counter play and he wants to
double rooks on D file and at some point
hope to execute a 5 Fischer pushes b5
and now immediately rook to e1 if you
capture first for example pawn captures
then you get pawn captures and after
rook to e1 B 4 is coming now you don't
really have the option of moving the
night you have to go with your plan e5
pawn captures and now Knight to e4 you
attack the Queen Queen's the g4 now kind
of pinning the night here and after
Bishop to e3 as it is attacked yes white
did get a passed pawn but it's not very
likely that it will ever break through
and white doesn't really have
compensation for the pawn so after b5
with rook 81 immediately by Spassky and
ok Queen to g6 spassky's idea was to
push a 5 so why not simply prevented
Queen to g6 if you push then you're
going to lose a pawn because after Queen
captures rook has to recapture there are
not enough defenders on the e5 square b3
rook to e7 by Fischer we have Queen to
d3 and then now comes Rock to b8 a
capture some b5 a capture some b5 and
now white doesn't really have a good
move here you still can't push a 5
you can't play a waiting move because if
you play something any waiting moved in
before it's coming and black wins the
game you move the knight Bishop to b5
Wednesday exchange and black is black is
out material in a better position enough
to win the game so Spassky has to push
be for himself now we have see for now
Fisher gets a nice past c-pawn Queen to
d2 and Dena comes rugby to e8 piling up
on that epon rook to e3 really there's
nothing better Bishop to g5 is
impossible you can't harass this frog
because of Bishop captures on c3 Queen
captures and you just lose a piece here
so rook to e3 by Spassky now comes h5
Fischer prepares to push the pawn we
have worked three to e2 as poss he
doesn't have a better option he just has
to wait and see what Fischer will do and
here a Fischer kind of tests the
patience of the world champion King - h7
rogue back to e3 and Fisher repeats came
to g8 just once rook three to e2 and now
as there Fischer can't find a way to
successfully break through in any way so
he decides to to at least grab a pond
and perhaps this will give him enough
advantage Bishop captures on c3 Queen
captures and now rook captures on e4
rook captures rook captures and rook
captures it might seem a bit odd to
exchange this rook as well and improved
the position of blacks Queen but ideas
like rook to a 1 followed by rook to e8
are easily met with rook to e8 and again
a White's position isn't any better
after rook to e4 Spassky captured the
rook rook captures Queen captures and
now comes Bishop to h6 threatening
checkmate on g7 it's not better to
capture on b6 you simply get Queen
captures on d5 you attack the bishop and
after Queen f6 defending you have Queen
to d1 check King moves and Bishop to c6
and it's all over you're getting
checkmated or whatever you play so after
Kea queenie for better to h6 Spassky
threatens checkmate on g7 now we have
Queen to g6 now simply preventing
checkmate and white now has to play
something there's really not all that
much to do your Bishop is under attack
push up to c1 and now comes Queen to be
won pinning the bishop we have king to
f1 as possible wants to get out of his
cage because you can't really stop
Bishop to f5 is coming to d3 or or
perhaps the e4 to f3 not a lot you can
do and it's often the case when there
are
of opposite colors here Fisher has a a
light square bishop Spassky has a dark
square Bishop and it will very often be
the case if you're the side that's
attacking it will it will feel like the
other side is down a piece because the
dark square Bishop cannot oppose a light
square bishop so okay King to f1 Spassky
tries to bring his king out of the cage
Bishop to a5 as we've already said King
to e2 and now comes Queen to e4 check
the strongest move by Bobby if we try
bush up to e4 with the idea of Bishop to
f3 then you get the Bishop to b2 again
checkmate is threatened and after Bishop
to f3 check King D to now you don't
really have a an option here you have to
prevent checkmate by f6 and then Queen
to c2 you have to play something you
have to exchange Queens here and then
you will really have to work hard to to
prove that you can actually win this
game in an opposite color bishops and
game so I'm tracking e to Queenie for
check now Fischer is forcing Spassky to
move his queen out of this very strong
diagonal Spassky plays Queen to e3 if
you tried moving your King it doesn't
really work King to f1 runs into a queen
h1 check King moves
now come special d3 check King moves and
now Queen to f3 threatening Queen to e2
so whatever you play you can threaten
checkmate but again
you grab the pawn king moves check King
moves now your check King moves and now
f6 and white has no moves little
literally no moves you can't capture
because of Nathan c2 and whatever you do
we are simply down too much material and
the black can win this game any way he
likes so like we said you have to move
the Queen out of this stronger
agonal Queen e3 we have Queen to c2 with
Czech Queen to d2 and Queen to b3 now
here official prepares to push his c3
pawn this is move 40 and you have to you
have to do something and here licorice
mentions like the same way Fischer made
a very incorrect move that completely
lost in the game in game 1
well he probably would have lost anyway
but at least at least there would be
some chances for him to save the game
Queen to d4 was played and now it's all
here it was a time to adjourn the game
and fish were sealed his move and of
course both Fischer and Spassky analyzed
this through the entire night but as
Pascal eco as both of them were very
long time as Pascack couldn't really
know which move Fischer sealed so it was
only the next day after they continued
the adjourned game that the chief
arbiter lauter Schmidt informed Spassky
that favor actually played Queen to the
Bishop to d3 check and Fischer didn't
even arrive to the game yet because he
was late but Spassky resigned
even before favour came after the board
so it was a very I mean it was it was
very sad it was the first time Fischer
ever defeated Spassky so they played
five times before the World Chess
Championship then he lost the game six
did they ever played in round one now
it's a game three and this is the first
time ever Fischer beat has beaten
Spassky and Fisher didn't even arrive at
the board so Spassky and congratulate
him personally and none of the official
didn't even hear the applause from the
crowd because he simply wasn't there but
yeah he resigned because after this
check there's really nothing to do after
a freaking - you won you get Queen
capture some before check you grab
another pawn and now whatever you do
white black and simply start pushing his
past points and it's all over nothing to
do here and on the other hand if you go
something like King to e3 still Queens
e1 so you threatened checkmate
whatever wise it does if Y threatens
checkmate Georgia is gonna bring the
King back and it will be either king c1
or king c3 will be met with Queen to c2
checkmate so yeah after this Bishop to
d3 the unsealed move Spassky resigned
the game and like we said the first ever
victory by Fischer / Spassky and
definitely this has taken a toll on
Spassky psyche as he could have ended
the match with with a single word he
could he could have just said no when a
lot of Schmidt called him and said no I
will not play under these ridiculous
terms I'm a world champ
I deserve to play on the main stage with
with lots of light and lots of cameras
and the audience you know enjoying my
presence which is pretty much something
that anyone would do
but that's why Spassky is such a
gentleman he allowed to play under such
terms because he he is simply a chess
player who wants to promote chess and he
wants to fight Fischer under under any
circumstances and you know under any
under any terms so that's that's what
kind of a guy Boris Spassky is he's just
the biggest chess gentleman you will you
will ever see so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and I really do hope
you're enjoying the Bobby Fischer series
so far sorry about no video yesterday I
have a couple of private matters I have
to attend to but I will try to make as
much content as possible as I really do
enjoy it and I really hope you enjoy it
as well I would also like to thank
Aurich Hoffmann Hamza Sam Robert
Sullivan Richard Fowler and baru
brothers and for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
most likely with Game four of this
Fischer Spassky match but perhaps there
will be a nice game in the Batumi Chess
Olympiad so perhaps an even a game from
there thank you all and I'll see you
soon